I got to go to summer game Fest play
days in person this year and I got some
cool Swag Bags I don't know what's in
them so I thought I would open them for
you and we have armed core six fires of
Rubicon as you can see first up
absolutely beautiful armored Core
notebook oh my God is this a mouse pad
what is this okay it's like a bath mat I
will be using this in my bathroom thank
you summer game Fest play days bag
itself that I think a whole bunch of
different companies were allowed to like
put stuff in an official Super Mario
Bros movie hat
cyberpunk art book okay this is a little
envelope that has a whole bunch of
stickers uh regarding Spotlight from
Quantic Dream Magic the Gathering
welcome booster okay little Naruto
Ultimate Ninja Storm connections fan
this is pretty cool these are postcards
summer game Fest socks this is an Alan
Wake to reference there is a code here
that contains uh Alan Wake remasted On
the epic game store that I will give
away in the comments